cette décision d'inclure ces détails
géographiques sur le maillot de la
sélection ukrainienne n'a pas manqué de
faire réagir faire pour moscou la crimée
est une région à part entière de la
russie et ce depuis le référendum de
rattachement de mars 2014 le kremlin
estiment que c'est du ressort de la fifa
et de l'uefa que de veiller à empêcher
toute politisation de ces compétitions
sportives tandis que du côté des
autorités de crime et on estime que
cette initiative n'est rien de moins
qu'une farce
tout cela n'est qu'une farce peu importe
ce que les athlètes et politiciens
ukrainiens dessine sur leur t-shirt la
réalité est complètement différente et
tout le monde le sait la crimée est une
région russe et il en sera toujours
ainsi
il n'y a pas que cette carte dessinée
sur le maillot il ya aussi les slogans
qui l'accompagnent gloire à l'ukraine
gloire aux héros pour la porte parole de
la diplomatie russe s'est slogan
rappelle les heures les plus sombres de
la seconde guerre mondiale pendant la
guerre ce cri de guerre nazis étaient
utilisées par des groupes armés
nationaliste régulier et régulier
opérant en ukraine dont la plupart
étaient fidèles au reich et certains
faisait officiellement partie de ses
forces armées au lendemain de la guerre
la tradition du salut à la bande des
rats a été maintenu et chérie par des
groupes criminels clandestins en ukraine
occidentale ainsi que par les
combattants de l'armée insurrectionnelle
ukrainienne qui se sont livrés aux
troupes américaines et ont échappé à la
justice en occident et ont vécu là bas
pour le restant de leurs jours
c'est donc avec cette polémique que va
débuter cet euro de football avec comme
adversaires les pays-bas pour l'ukraine
et la belgique pour la russie depuis de
nombreuses années les instances
internationales du football évident que
se rencontrent l'ukraine et la russie
même si dans une compétition comme
l'euro il n'est pas exclu que ces deux
équipes puissent se rencontrer au moment
des phases finales